we begin this half-hour with the
devastating effects of the world's
pollution environmental pollution
contributed to the premature deaths of
about nine million people in 2015 that
is nearly 15 times as many deaths from
war and all forms of violence that
staggering figure comes from a study
published this week in the medical
journal The Lancet here's Anna Werner
this guy is gonna act like it's
breathing with me New Yorker Chelsea
Yamada is wearing a special vest on her
commute measuring her exposure to air
pollution it's part of a multi-year
study looking at pollution hotspots and
the impact on cyclists health
it's smoky it's thick and you get
trapped sometimes if you're really in
their tailpipe sucking it all in despite
recent efforts to curb pollution a major
new report from The Lancet shows more
needs to be done the study found more
people died from exposure to dirty air
than from health factors including
obesity alcohol and a high sodium diet
dr. Philip Landrigan of the Icahn School
of Medicine at Mount Sinai most of these
deaths are caused by chronic diseases
specifically by heart disease stroke
lung cancer chronic obstructive lung
disease nearly 92 percent of the deaths
occurred in developing countries with
China and India most affected and
children are at the highest risk but
each year pollution also kills an
estimated 155 thousand people in the US
yet the report says pollution can be
addressed in the 45 years since the u.s.
passed the Clean Air Act air pollution
here has dropped 70% the control of
pollution actually saves money because
it prevents illness it extends life it
helps the productivity of economies in
the United States and in countries
around the world
dr. Landrigan points out that the gross
domestic product in the US has increased
250% since the Clean Air Act was put in
place in 1970 he says that's proof that
countries can have wealth and prosperity
and clean air Alex and Anthony boy the
drop in
in this country is pretty impressive but
but I have to say I was really stunned
by the degree to which pollution impacts
people's health deadly it is deadly
stuff yeah